[Música]
flanqueado por dos poderosas naciones
europeas el Canal de la Mancha ha sido
uno de los pasajes marítimos más
importantes sin embargo durante la mayor
parte de su historia las costas rocosas
del Canal y su clima tormentoso hicieron
peligroso cruzarlo ingenieros de
principios de 1800 propusieron numerosos
planes para atravesar la brecha de 33
kilómetros
sus diseños incluían Islas artificiales
unidas por puentes tubos sumergidos
suspendidos desde plataformas flotantes
y un pasaje submarino con una longitud
más de dos veces mayor que la de
cualquier túnel existente a finales de
siglo Esta última propuesta había
capturado la imaginación Europea
la invención de la tuneladora y el
descubrimiento de una capa estable de
marca calcárea debajo del fondo Marino
hicieron más factible este fantástico
túnel
pero ningún ingeniero pudo resolver los
obstáculos más urgentes del proyecto
en ese momento los británicos vieron su
aislamiento geográfico como una ventaja
estratégica y los temores sobre una
invasión francesa hicieron cancelar los
planes del túnel el surgimiento de la
guerra aérea volvió estas preocupaciones
obsoletas pero surgieron nuevas
preocupaciones económicas para
reemplazarlas finalmente 100 años
después de la excavación inicial los dos
países llegaron a un acuerdo el túnel se
haría con financiación privada en 1985
un grupo de empresas francesas y
británicas invirtieron el equivalente a
14 mil millones de libras actuales
haciendo del túnel el proyecto de
infraestructura más caro hasta la fecha
el diseño requería tres túneles
separados uno para trenes a Francia uno
para trenes a Inglaterra y un túnel de
servicio entre ellos
junto a cámaras cruzadas pasajes de
emergencia y conductos de aire esto
ascendió a más de 200 kilómetros de
túneles en 1988 se comenzó a excavar
desde ambos lados con el plan de
reunirse en el medio estudios de la
costa francesa mostraron que el sitio
presentaba fallas sísmicas estas grietas
permitían que se filtrara agua en La
Roca Así que los ingenieros tuvieron que
desarrollar toneladoras impermeables los
británicos anticiparon condiciones más
secas y avanzaron con perforadores
regulares pero a solo unos meses de
comenzada la obra entró agua a través de
fisuras no detectadas para perforar la
caliza húmeda los británicos usaron
lechada para sellar las grietas creadas
en la Estela de la barrena y trabajaron
antes de la barrena principal para
reforzar la caliza a perforar
con estos obstáculos superados ambos
equipos comenzaron a perforar a toda
velocidad
barrenas de hasta 1300 toneladas
perforaban a casi 3,5 metros por hora
mientras cavaban instalaron anillos de
revestimiento para estabilizar el túnel
detrás de ellos abriendo paso a los
vagones de apoyo que seguían a cada
máquina incluso a toda velocidad el
trabajo tenía que proceder con cuidado
la capa de caliza hacía un camino
sinuoso entre roca inestable y arcilla
punzadas por más de 100 agujeros
perforados por agrimensores anteriores
además ambos equipos tenían que
verificar constantemente sus coordenadas
para asegurarse de estar en camino de
encontrarse mutuamente para mantener la
trayectoria los barrenadores empleaban
sistemas de posicionamientos satelital
así como paleontólogos que usaban
fósiles excavados para confirmar que
estuvieran a la profundidad correcta
durante la construcción el proyecto
empleó a más de 13.000 personas y costó
la vida de diez trabajadores
pero después de dos años y medio de
tunelización los dos lados finalmente
hicieron contacto el trabajador
británico Grand apareció en el lado
francés y se convirtió en el primer
humano en cruzar el canal por tierra
desde la edad de hielo Aunque daba
trabajo por hacer desde instalar cámaras
cruzadas y estaciones de bombeo a
colocar más de 160 kilómetros de
circuitos cables y sensores pero el 6 de
mayo de 1994 una ceremonia de apertura
marcó la finalización del túnel 16 meses
después comenzó el servicio público
completo con trenes para pasajeros y
transportadores ferroviarios para autos
y camiones actualmente el túnel del
Canal sirve a más de 20 millones de
pasajeros al año transporta pasajeros a
través del canal en solo 35 minutos
desafortunadamente no todos tienen el
privilegio de hacer este viaje
legalmente miles de refugiados han
intentado entrar a Gran Bretaña a través
del túnel en intentos a veces fatales
estas tragedias han transformado la
entrada sur del túnel en un sitio de
continuo conflicto con suerte la
historia de la estructura puede servir
como recordatorio de que la humanidad
está en su mejor momento al derribar
barreras
Explore los 800 años de historia y
arquitectura de la torre inclinada de
Pisa y descubra que le da a la torre su
famosa inclinación con este video